cécile cros et oléo log c'est une
spécialiste des huiles d'olive habitante
de villennes-sur-seine l'animé ce soir
là un atelier au café ouzou de paris
pour transmettre sa passion qui ravit
c'est un cadeau de mes enfants pour mon
anniversaire je pas si théorique c'est
le mot mais avoir un peu plus de culture
lié à l'huile d'olive et pas seulement
être un simple amateur l'atelier divisé
en trois parties deux premières étapes
pour découvrir l'huile d'olive savoir
reconnaître les différentes odeurs et
saveurs
une fois ces connaissances plus concrète
vient la dernière étape a semblé sa
propre huile d'olive ils ont eu besoin
en fait au préalable de connaître les
différents fruité l'amertume le piquant
les notes qu'on peut avoir en et ils ont
eu besoin de s'entraîner et de connaître
ces différents frites et pour après a
semblé et jg était voilà moi j'aime pas
trop la mère kim et piquant gens mais je
met moins de celle ci plus de celle ci
en parallèle à ces ateliers c'est si
l'on possède son oliveraie une vocation
découverte en 2007 c'est vraiment le
hasard à 30 ans je suis allé vivre à
barcelone si rejoint mon mari qui
vivaient là bas et
et on a acheté cette livrée un peu par
hasard entre guillemets pour avoir un
pied-à-terre le week-end et puis on
s'est lancé dans l'aventuré aujourd'hui
l'eau les eaux log yvelinoise alterne
entre la catalogne et villennes sur
seine où elle entrepose ses huiles
cécile possède environ 4000 bouteilles
de 500 millilitres pour les vendre elle
a ses préférences
moi j'aime bien faire les ventes
directes parce que je fait déguster les
huiles et je fais une mini dégustation
une mini initiation à l'oenologie en
même temps et puis les gens peuvent
goûter les différentes villes donc qu'on
des frites est différent et peut se
choisir ensuite au mieux leur ville elle
souhaite faire valoir l'huile d'olive
non comme un ajout de matière grasse
mais plutôt un ajout de saveurs d'arômes
dans un plat crus ou cuits
son petit plus insolites l'huile dans
les desserts dans des fruits des salles
de frites et salade d'orange on peut
mettre un beau fruité vert un peu
piquant amer sur un cocktail ou une
glace ça ramène du peps à massat ramène
du verre et ça je trouve ça chouette
s'étonnant l'huile de divan en dessert
en plus des marchés de vilaines triel
sur seine ou à cheval les huiles de
cécile sont à la vente sur son site
internet qu va tirer foum adapco